talking about fusing the global world
with with values as being sort of how to
make globalization human but that almost
assumes that there isn't an existing set
of values within the neoliberal
structures themselves of economics and
politics and and I would argue that
there are a set of values that are there
that you know this economic crisis that
is reviewing these tensions is actually
not new you know the profound inequality
of this world is in crisis that we've
been living in in my mind some of the
structures within neoliberalism have
created and so isn't there inevitably
actually a conflict for a person coming
with a value for the collective good who
is adherent to a purely neoliberal
economic model um well then maybe and de
facto there certainly are right don't we
actually need to be changing the
structures themselves also yeah but I
mean I think you've got to distinguish
between as it will what's the answer in
technical terms and what are the values
that are underpinning the the effort to
find that answer so you know if there
were a neoliberal City here here's the
problem is that I'm never quite sure
myself you know you know they might
argue in certain circumstances that
actually there's there's does lead to a
more just outcome I'll leave that to one
side the quick the question is is what
is the test what is it that you're
trying to achieve you know are you
trying and if you are merely trying to
achieve the most neoliberal system that
you can
then that's obviously you know that's
that's not something that's born over of
a desire to to implement certain values
but there are circumstances in which
liberalisation can be a value that leads
to greater justice yeah okay come on so
yeah just um so that's sort of an
extreme in extreme neoliberal individual
so so but we have an individual who may
not be an extreme neoliberal having an
extremely liberal perspective but
operating and neoliberal structures that
have been established over the course of
globalization so the question is more is
that that public figure of faith who
desires you know is collective good
don't they actually need to challenge
the system in which they're operated
well how do you define the system in
this respect I mean how do you what do
you think the structures are that are
problematic sure the there's an elite
international development structure that
even in solving solutions even in the
idea of development is one that both
politically places a whole lot of power
within an elites in a league context so
it's a even the democratic form that our
state's take it's a step removed from a
more collective form of participation
both economically and politically and so
you know you have policy decisions that
are being made about how to do
development in the world made by the
World Bank by IMF that then are enforced
on nations who in order to participate
have to adopt some of the more
privatization trends of the world for
example even at the cost of indigenous
views of what democracy and economic
systems might look like so you know
I can think of South Africa for example
where in post-apartheid there's a move
towards adopting a more privatization
model that was different from the
original ANC platform which has brought
global capital to South Africa one could
argue but there's an increasing still to
this day inequality within the country
but I think Alison what i would do is i
distinguish between good and bad policy
and and that issue and what are the
values that we're trying to ascertain
you see i mean i think one of the things
that that i think is that actually
globalization is basically i mean i
think it's fact and it's inevitable but
i also think it's a good thing in the
sense that it does break down barriers
between people but i think that without
a value system to go alongside and
policy that supports that value system
then it can lead to injustice and
reaction to the whole process of
globalization now I what I would say to
you is that you could have good or bad
policy but I mean the people at the
World Bank and the IMF I mean this has
been a debate over the years is it good
for the country to privatize or is it
bad that's a good or bad policy debate
and you can find people of faith and
people who believe in justice and equity
on both sides of that argument that's
that's all I'm saying I think that's
different from saying the structure its
itself needs to be changed I mean I
don't I don't know how you know all I'm
saying is that whatever policy decision
you take it is better that policy
decision is informed by a discussion of
values and not simply interests